I know you love the original story and
the original film yeah what was it about
that that you connected to that you hope
kids today will connect to this version
the initial thing that I would hope for
kids to take us is just this idea of you
know the friendship between a boy who at
first lost everything he's lost his
family and yet he has this beautiful
friendship with the dragon that idea of
friendship and how healing friendship
can be in and how you know and to see
what it takes to find your family i mean
i think that's that's a very very
emotional very meaningful story that
both films certainly have such a special
relationship pate has with his dragon
Elliott so Oaks when it came to creating
that relationship did you draw on
anything from your own life I'm not like
Pete in certain ways and then I am like
him than others um Elliot I guess and
Pete have this odd relationship and it's
I guess saying that even though somebody
can be completely different than you you
can still be very good friends with them
I love that that's such a great message
and i have to say i need to start your
career but i'm already jealous of you
you got to work with my pretend feature
husband Jake Gyllenhaal and now with
Robert Redford when you work with these
actors do you feel like you learned from
them every time I really think I do I
mean even if they don't give me direct
advice just like seeing them act and do
what they do is just like such a
privilege I love your character is the
storyteller and he talks about having
belief in something that you may not be
able to see and I was wondering if you
could draw any parallels or if you did
do that between yourself and the
character when it comes to sorry I think
that there's a very close association
because I feel the same way and I have
much of my life that there's always more
than what's in front of you there's
always more to see than what's in the
immediate vicinity and so the idea being
able to put that idea into a film it was
very appealing
you